it's election day in the united states
and today and all this week
we'll be looking at the impact of the
vote on countries across asia
one of the most important relationships
for the u.s and the indo-pacific
is its engagement with india the two
countries together with japan
and australia form part of what is known
as the quad for democracies
in a clear counterpoint to china the
region's large authoritarian state
we sat down with india's foreign
secretary harshvardhan shringla
to discuss regional politics we started
by asking him
whether there be any change with a biden
presidency especially given president
donald trump
and prime minister narendra modi's great
personal admiration for each other
our relations with the united states are
really based on
bipartisan support you see it in
congress
you see it uh you know at the public
levels
we do believe that we've forged a
relationship that today
is has withstood the test of time is uh
is very comprehensive and multifaceted
we not only share the same values and
principles but we also
i think have the same strategic vision
in what
could be a bilateral regional or
multilateral
relationship now prime minister modi's
relationship with president trump have
been special
but you have to remember that prime
minister modi's relationship with
president obama was also very special
i remember that state dinner that
president obama held
am i correct in in hearing that you
believe that regardless
of who wins the presidency in the united
states the relationship will
fundamentally not change
vice president biden who is
the democratic candidate has also made
it very clear in many of his statements
that he values
a strong india u.s strategic partnership
so that is common to both
president trump and president biden now
i want to talk a little bit about the
quad
um and and the recent meeting there
you have australia japan united states
and india like-minded countries
their shared value of being democracies
i imagine that if you were sitting in
beijing it kind of looks like
encirclement
how would you respond to people who say
that
well um the court is
a grouping of countries which have us
which have the same vision
of a free open uh transparent
indo-pacific region
an international rules based order
international freedom navigation in in
global commons
and also issues such as open
connectivity
uh respecting the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of states
essentially working to bolster the the
capacities
and the abilities of countries in the
indo-pacific with asean as
its entirety in a manner that is both
constructive and cooperative
you mentioned open connectivity and
borders let's talk about borders first
and the last 24 hours there's been a
report in bloomberg about the fact that
some 300 square kilometers that used to
be
administered by india is now
administered by china and i'd be
interested in your response or comments
to that report clearly there we believe
that
you know the situation has involved
some level of deterioration in terms of
uh
it has contributed iteration in terms of
the ties between our two countries
because of the
unusual step of china to seek to
unilaterally alter the status quo you
have to keep in mind that there is no
common perception in the border
but yet if you you know seek to
change where the current you know
line where troops are then of course it
does impact on the larger relationship
we are concerned
that china has taken this step we are
very very clear that we will stand firm
and resolute
in our uh resolve not to allow our
territorial integrity or sovereignty to
be compromised
but i want to make sure do you confirm
or deny
the characterization from the report
that china is actually administrating
300 kilometers square kilometers more of
territory that they did not have at the
start of this year
well i'm not aware of where bloomberg is
getting its information from
but i can tell you that as far as we are
concerned uh says indian officials
familiar with the situation
you're asking me and i'm telling you
that as far as we are concerned we will
not
compromise on our territorial integrity
great i want to ask about another um
neighbor of yours
in terms of relationships up pakistan's
prime minister imran khan
recently called india a fascist state
inspired by the nazi regime this is what
he said
to a german news outlet what is your
response to that
well i can only say that is ripe coming
from the prime minister of a country
that does not recognize the state of
israel
that till now does not acknowledge that
the holocaust took place
that has provided a safe sanctuary for
osama bin laden
and mullah omar of the taliban years
after 9 11
a country that today has a debt which is
higher than his gdp
a country that has enormous
socio-economic problems and political
problems now with an
entire coalition of all the opposition
parties
seeking to unseat prime minister imran
khan
and those who back him from the deep
state and
it is clearly an attempt to distract
international attention uh and domestic
attention from his own problems
that iran khan is making this this
statement i mean i mean considering
his situation and pakistan's own
approach towards radicalism terrorism
and issues that are important to the
international community he really
shouldn't be making such
irresponsible statements
you'll allow me this question as someone
who's born in hong kong
you talk about rules based a lot of
rules can be interpreted to have been
broken in hong kong is this
a matter of concern for india
as as a matter of policy we don't
comment on on what
becomes the internal affairs of states
we have said that uh
there is a large community of indian
origin there's a large indian community
in hong kong so we're watching the
situation with
some level of attention and concern and
we will continue to do so
secretary shingla thank you very much
thank you so very much melissa
we have ananth krishnan in chennai
joining us to provide more context
following our interview with the foreign
secretary
he is the hindus china correspondent and
also the author of
india's china challenge ananth we just
heard the foreign secretary there
not really giving a clear response about
whether china really did
capture all that territory your thoughts
i think melissa it is understandable uh
for two reasons
i think uh the first is negotiations are
ongoing they've had seven
really unsuccessful rounds of talks at
the military level that have gone
nowhere
and i think that that's why they're
being a little iconic i think that the
second reason is it is a domestic
political issue in india and the modi
government has been coming under fire
from the opposition
for really not handling the china
problem at the border
so i think the government doesn't really
want to come out and say they've lost so
much territory but i think
uh from my own point of view melissa
right from the start i think
the government really could have been a
little bit more transparent and it could
have actually helped india dealing with
this
by showing to the world that it was
china that had occupied this territory
and
sought to redraw the line of actual
control and the government could have
actually publicly taken a stand and told
china listen these are the red lines
we have to return to status quo so i
think i find it a little puzzling
why the government's actually been so
reluctant to actually
spell out what actually the underground
situation is along the line of actual
control
and where china has made ingresses and
occupied territory
do you think there's a lack of trust on
the indian side when they look at the
activities of the chinese in the south
china sea
that they can never really speak to the
chinese and
come up with a resolution on the border
issue but unfortunately melissa that's
the only way i don't think
either country really wants a full-on
conflict
and as difficult as it is i think it's
going to be a combination of continuing
to talk at various levels between
military commanders between diplomats in
beijing and delhi
but at the same time keeping up a very
firm defensive posture as india has done
and an end august india actually
occupied several strategic heights
that have given it some bargaining power
in the negotiations that it did not have
previously so i think the hope is both
sides can find a meeting of minds but i
think
there is still some skepticism in india
with china after mobilizing all these
troops in early may
they really walk back from all the
territory they've gained i think that's
something that
is going to be very difficult for india
to achieve a full return to status quo
which is what india has publicly
demanded
well this is election week so i'm
curious do you agree with secretary
shringle's assessment
that the bilateral relationship between
india and the us
won't change regardless of who wins
either trump or biden
i would broadly agree that i think the
basic sort of uh
motivations of the india u.s
relationship won't change it's quite
interesting melissa that india is a bit
unique among many countries and actually
having quite a fond
sort of experience dealing with trump
over the last four years
there have been issues on trade i mean
who hasn't had issues with trump on
trade
uh but in terms of the defense
relationship in terms of the strategic
relationship
actually the india u.s relationship has
done fairly well under donald trump
and with the prime minister modi just
one evidence of that just last week week
before the election
you had secretary of state mike pompeo
and the defense secretary mark esper
come to delhi for talks just a week
before the election
i think the message really was from the
u.s that this is going to be a long-term
strategic relationship
and the fact that they signed uh the
fourth really important military defense
agreement
uh for sharing geospatial uh information
i think it really shows how even though
they aren't officially allies there is a
very very close defense partnership
that is growing even more close and
growing even more stronger
and regardless of whether it's trump or
biden in the white house i think that is
going to continue
there is going to be broad continuity
even if there will be some differences
i think one minor point of concern for
india is the democrat administration
tends to be more outspoken on issues
such as human rights
situation in kashmir something where
trump really didn't want to get involved
so i think the indian government is
aware there will be small changes but i
think there is a realization that
the broad controls of the relationship
really have a bipartisan resonance in
washington right now
i think that's a huge positive for the
india u.s relationship
and a sign of how much it's grown over
the last 10-15 years
where else do you see the us and india
working together
i think melissa one big gap is when it
comes to economic
cooperation i think that uh india us
australia and japan
the so-called quad have done quite a bit
in terms of security ties
they're going to be having huge
exercises the malabar naval exercises
this week
where really i think they have lagged
behind isn't actually coming up and
providing an alternative
to countries in the region in asia
when it comes to financing where they're
all reliant on chinese financing still
even though there has been some push
back to the belt and road initiative
we hear from countries such as sri lanka
for instance
where else can they go for funding there
really aren't many other sources besides
china and i think really other countries
should step up if they really want to
provide a credible
alternative to china in the region quite
frankly minnesota they haven't done
enough
anand krishnan thank you